نشير مشاهدينا الى العواجل التي تريدنا
تباعا من بيان صعود ايراني صيني حيث يقول
هذا البيان بان بكين استضافت المباحثات
بين الرياض وطهران في الفتره من السادس
وحتى العاشر من مارس والذي افضى الى
الاتفاق على تعزيز التعاون بين طهران
والرياض في عده مجالات وايضا اتفاق على
مناقشه سبل تعزيز العلاقات وتفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني قبل ذلك اشار البيان الى
ان الى هناك ترتيبات تبادل السفراء بين
الرياض وطهران وستتم على مدى شهرين واتفاق
يتضمن احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في
شؤونها الداخليه البيان السعودي الايراني
الصيني اشار مشاهدينا ايضا الى اتفاق على
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه السعوديه وايران كذلك
وايضا طهران والرياض تشكران بكين على
جهودها لانجاح المباحثات طهران والرياض
شكرت كذلك سلطنه عمان لدورها
في استضافتهما في جولات الحوار وكذلك
العراق اذا بيان سعودي ايراني صيني على
اعاده العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه هذا
البيان اشار مشاهدينا الى ان بكين قامت
باستضافه المباحثات بين الرياض وطهران ما
بين السادس حتى العاشر من مارس الشهر
الجاري وان الاتفاق على تعزيز التعاون بين
طهران والرياض في عده مجالات ذكر كذلك في
البيان
وهناك ايضا اتفاق على ترتيب تبادل السفراء
بين ايران وطهران خلال الشهرين القادمه
البيان السعودي الايراني الصيني اشار ايضا
الى اتفاقنا على اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
السعوديه وايران ولكن لم يتم تحديد الوقت
بالتاكيد الاتفاق يتضمن ايضا احترام سياده
الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
وايضا يتضمن استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
خلال شهرين كما قبل قليل بيان السعودي
الايراني الصيني مشاهدينا ايضا اشار الى
ان طهران والرياض تشكران بكين على جهودها
لانجاح هذه المباحثات وقام البيان ايضا
بشكر كل من عمان والعراق لاستضافتهما
جولات حوار ايضا بين الجانبين السعودي
والايراني اتفاق على استئناف العلاقات بين
الرياض وطيران جاء في بيان سعودي ايراني
صيني وايضا اجتماع قريب بين وزيره خارجيه
السعوديه وايران واتفقت الدولتين على
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه في غضون شهرين
اذا نعيد بالتذكير في العواجل التي وردتنا
قبل قليل في الشان الايراني السعودي
مشاهدينا حيث خرج بيان سعودي ايراني صيني
تحدث عن ان بكين استضافت المباحثات بين
الرياض وطهران في الفتره ما بين السادس
وحتى العاشر من مارس الجاري وايضا في
البيان الجانب السعودي والايراني شكراء
الصين على استضافه هذه المباحثات وعلى
انجاح الحوار وشكرت ايضا الجانب العماني
والعراقي على استضافتهما لبعض من الحوارات
بين الجانبين وايضا اتفقا على تعزيز
التعاون بين طهران والرياض في عده مجالات
من بينها تعزيز الامن والعلاقات وتفعيل
اتفاقيه التعاون الامني وكذلك تم الاتفاق
على تبادل السفراء بين الرياض وطهران هذا
البيان اشار الى اتفاق على اجتماع لوزراء
خارجيه البلدين وزراء خارجيه كل من
السعوديه وايران ولكن لم يتم تحديد
التاريخ
والاتفاق يتضمن كذلك احترام سياده الدول
وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه وكان هذا
الجانب مهم بالنسبه للسعوديه كذلك الاتفاق
يتضمن كذلك استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
خلال الشهرين
القادمه معنا